so I'm pretty certain you've been given
the advice don't care what other people
think but here's why you should think
twice before passing this advice on to
someone else you have what I thought was
a pretty hot take in the book which is
that this whole thing of don't care what
other people think is not necessarily
like good advice yeah because we are
here we are social beings aren't that
aren't we and however much you tell
someone not to care what other people
think they are built to care and if you
didn't you wouldn't be a very social
person right you know if I was in here
and not caring what anybody else thought
of me I could be really anti-social and
destroy relationships that I could have
otherwise made and then I'm not going to
fare very well if I'm not able to
maintain relationships and so there are
opinions that matter some matter more
than others and I think it's all about
that is working out whose opinions do I
value yeah and how can I then manage the
the discomfort if those people whose
opinions I value disapprove of me or
criticize me in some way and then
there's a whole set of skills around you
know managing criticism and things like
that